connaissez-vous le point commun entre le
post it
le velcro
la tarte tatin
il viagra
la réponse est là c'est randy pitt et
mais qu'est ce que c'est la sérendipité
est l'art de trouver quelque chose que
l'on ne cherche pas c'est comme chercher
une aiguille dans une botte de foin et
il trouvait la fille du fermier
la sérendipité
n'est pas le hasard elle est un heureux
mélange entre la sagacité et l'intuition
hockey prenons un exemple concret
comment le post it a été découvert
nous sommes en 1974 art frei est employé
de la société 3m et c'est un chanteur de
chorales
il a pour habitude de découper des
petits morceaux de papier pour annoter
les chansons qu'il veut chanter dans sa
couronne le problème est qu'à la moindre
occasion il s'envole
à fra et décida donc d'en parler à son
collègue chercheurs qui travaillent sur
le dosage des cols forte
son collègue lui avoua avoir créé une
colle qui ne colle pas il s'était trompé
dans les dosages du coup cette colle
était inutile sauf
pour arte frei qui grâce à son intuition
imagine pouvoir coller sur ces petits
bouts de papier un petit peu de colle et
pouvoir a noté son livre et c'est comme
ça qu'est né le post-it dès la fin des
années 70 la société 3m dépose à la
marque et débute à la commercialisation
et vous que peut vous apporter la
sérendipité je suis certain que
plusieurs d'entre vous enfant déjà sans
le savoir
je vais vous raconter au travers de
quelques exemples comment la série andy
pitt et a impacté positivement ma vie
durant mes études universitaires
j'ai dû réaliser un stage à l'étranger
pour valider mon diplôme lors de la
réunion prestage nous devions nous
positionner sur un pays
mes amis ont
logiquement choisi la destination la
plus fun à savoir les états unis en mode
spring break
il avait eu des échos sur les stages qui
était proposé plutôt cool ou la
principale difficulté était de se lever
le matin
c'est mon tour
je décide à la dernière minute de partir
en pologne
la pologne au milieu des années 90 sort
juste du giron communiste et la pologne
c'est ça un petit peu moins fun
je vous laisse imaginer la tête de mes
amis quand j'ai annoncé mon choix au
mieux ils m'ont pris pour un quelqu'un
de pas trop normal au pire pour un fou
complètement fou mais en fait il était
mort de rire
en fait j'ai décidé la pologne de faire
ce choix parce que pour la première fois
j'allais pouvoir sortir du cadre
sécuritaire dans lequel j'avais été
éduqué j'allais pouvoir sortir de ma
zone de confort apprendre une nouvelle
langue de nouvelles habitudes et surtout
avoir des responsabilités que seul un
pays en voie de développement peuvent
vous offrir à 22 ans
au final l'expérience fut très
enrichissante et très valorisante j'ai
réalisé les études de marché pour
l'implantation du premier magasin
décathlon à varsovie
au niveau personnel j'ai eu la chance
d'être hébergés dans des familles
polonaises qui m'ont fait découvrir la
pologne de l'intérieur et vivre des
moments inoubliables
j'ai encore en souvenir un week-end de
kayak où nous avions traversé la région
des mille lacs et nous avions été
hébergés chez l'habitant
c'est d'ailleurs à cette occasion que
j'ai découvert l'origine de l'expression
saoul comme un polonais mais ça c'est
une autre histoire
grâce à cette expérience j'ai senti
l'importance de casser la routine de la
divergence la richesse de sortir des
sentiers battus cette expérience m'a
initié à l'international et m'a permis
de développer mes capacités d'adaptation
lorsque j'ai parlé de ce toc à une amie
maryse elle m'a dit écoute francs que
j'ai rencontré mon mari avec ce que tu
appelles la sérendipité ce qui commence
à la sérendipité permet également
trouver l'âme soeur génial je vais
apprendre la recette magique et pouvant
vous la partagez
maryse et est parti six mois en congé
sabbatique durant son voyage en asie du
sud est elle avait utilisé le couch
surfing le couchsurfing est un moyen
d'héberger des voyageurs est de
favoriser les rencontres fortuites
à son retour à la réunion elle a décidé
de rendre la pareille et donc elle
héberge des voyageurs chez elle isabelle
une coach refuse qu'elle avait hébergé
chez elle l'invitant en soir à dîner
dans sa colocation à la réunion entre
temps elle s'était installée à la
réunion évidemment elle parlait de
voyage durant le repas un de ces
colloques s'incruste à
prétextant être lui aussi fan de voyage
ils passèrent une superbe soirée ils
échangèrent sur l'asie du sud-est leur
philosophie du voyage quitte à en
oublier un petit peu isabelle
à mois après ils en ménagère ensemble
un an après
il partait ensemble à madagascar pour
une mission professionnelle deux ans
après ils avaient leur premier enfant
aujourd'hui cinq ans après nous sommes à
la réunion heureux et parents de deux
petites filles et vous vous l'avez
deviné le fameux colloque qui s'est
incrusté c'était moi
c'est aussi ça la sérendipité suivre les
connexions les événements suivre vos
émotions et voir où cela vous mène
au niveau professionnel la sérendipité
fait partie intégrante de mon activité
mon métier est de trouver des solutions
aux problématiques des entreprises je
suis à la recherche constante
d'information et de contacts
l'ouverture au monde et le développement
des connexions et sont les piliers de
mon activité
je travaille depuis quelques années dans
un espace de coworking
c'est un espace hybride entre un bureau
classique et la maison où on peut
travailler se détendre rencontre aidé
d'autres entrepreneurs et assister à des
conférences et c'est dans ce cadre là
que j'ai rencontré beaucoup
d'entreprises
certains sont devenus des partenaires
d'autres des clients
en août dernier je rendais visite à un
espace de coworking à saint-etienne dans
la rue j'aperçois une boutique de bd
qui avait eu l'idée ingénieuse de faire
défiler de manière verticale cbd pour
animer sa vitrine vous allez dire quel
intérêt
la sérendipité c'est aussi la capacité à
lier les idées les personnes et les
événements en fait avant de partir un
client m'avait dit
peux-tu me faire une veille sur les
idées un peu innovante d'agencement de
magasin de carrelage
bingo
grâce à cette boutique de bd jallet
proposé à mon client une idée neuve
pour
agencer sa vitrine de carrelage
imaginez un magasin de carrelage qui
mettrait directement dans sa vitrine le
carrelage comme ça qu'ils défileraient
plutôt sympa et plutôt ingénieux comme
idée
ok j'ai pas réussi à vendre cette idée à
mon client mais il a souligné
effectivement ma créativité et mon sens
de l'innovation
depuis
2007 année d'arrivée à la réunion j'ai
travaillé sur de nombreux projets
dans le domaine des tennis et de
l'éducation la formation du tourisme
j'ai laissé aussi de côté un certain
nombre de projets vous pourriez me dire
mais
comment sais tu que les projets que tu
as choisis sont les bons
en fait je sais pas c'est parce que
j'étais préparée que j'ai vu une
opportunité en fait les projets que j'ai
choisi résonnait en moi
le dernier projet dans lequel jamais
investi est en lien avec l'humanitaire
et encore une fois j'aime à dire que
c'est le projet qui est venu vers moi je
vous explique
il ya quelques semaines j'arrive au
bureau joue facebook pour regarder ce
qui s'est passé durant la soirée et
j'aperçois un article sur un concours
mondial qui a pour objectif d' éradiquer
l'illettrisme en afrique et dans le
monde
génial je m'empresse aussitôt de le
partager à mes amis facebook
jusqu'à là ça nous arrive tous
surprise quelques jours après je retombe
sur un article d'une équipe réunionnaise
qui est en train de se monter pour
répondre à ce concours je me dis c'est
incroyable c'est un projet inouïe et en
partie si participer serait une belle
aventure pour moi surtout que quelques
semaines auparavant j'étais à maurice et
j'assistais à une conférence sur des
projets d'éducation et dtic en afrique
anglophone
je ne pouvais pas laisser passer cette
chance
aujourd'hui nous en sommes au tout début
du projet nous allons candidate et d'ici
quelques jours est proposé donc notre
équipe à la fondation américaine x prize
qui
devra faire ses sélections pour choisir
quelques équipes dans le monde entier
pour participer au mois de mars j'ai
vraiment hâte d'y être ce projet est
pour moi comme une consécration de on va
dire des dix dernières années
ce que je voulais partager avec vous
aujourd'hui l enchaînement des
opportunités et les facteurs qui les
provoque
il n'y a pas de hasard dans les
opportunités et à chaque moment votre
vie peut être prise en main
être en mouvement
accueillir la divergence
s'ouvrir au monde
observez ressentais engagez vous
prenez soin de vos connexions
et surtout soyez prêts à accueillir la
sérendipité
il faut savoir aujourd'hui que la
sérendipité fait partie de la stratégie
des entreprises prenons par exemple
google google permet à ses salariés de
travailler 20 % de leur temps
normalement dédiée à l'entreprise sur
des projets personnels
l'objectif évidemment favoriser les
découvertes fortuites
bravo à vous en assistant à ce tedx
réunion 2014 vous venez de débuter vos
20 % merci